bruno retrouver alix le bourdon à
bruxelles puisque dans la foulée de
cette conférence de presse emmanuel
macron symbole pour pour bruxelles où va
se tenir c'est ces deux prochains jours
le sixième sommet union européenne union
africaine rendez vous pendant lequel va
se jouer l'avenir des relations entre
l'afrique et l'europe bruno évoqué cette
béquille européenne pour le chef de
l'état français c'est la réalité a
aujourd'hui
en effet c'était très important pour la
france pour emmanuel macron de faire
cette annonce ce matin dans un cadre
multilatéral et notamment on l'a dit au
côté de charles michel le président du
conseil européen surtout que vous l'avez
dit on est maintenant à quelques heures
du début d'un grand sommet ici à
bruxelles qui va durer deux jours un
sommet entre l'union africaine et
l'union européenne c'est le premier
depuis cinq ans et il devrait y avoir 40
des 55 dirigeants de l'union africaine
d'ailleurs dans son discours 1 ce matin
emmanuel macron a évoqué ce sommet il
sera l'occasion de travailler sur un
modèle de partenariat équilibré 1 at il
dit pendant son discours emmanuel macron
c'est d'ailleurs plusieurs fois posé en
tant que le chef d'état qui est à la
tête de la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne dans son introduction
il a dit que l'europe et est un
partenaire de confiance allaient aux
côtés de la cedeao alors européaniser à
cette question de la lutte anti
djihadistes au sahel ça fait déjà
plusieurs mois que la france essaie de
le faire pour montrer un finalement et
bien qu'elle n'est pas seule dans cette
région c'est d'ailleurs la france qui en
2018 avait eu l'idée de lancer cette
taskforce takouba qui est une coalition
de forces spéciales européennes à l'idée
évidemment eh bien c'était déjà
d'impliquer davantage les partenaires
européens quel avenir justement alix
pour les forces européennes au sel on
sent bien qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes autour de cette question
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron charles
michel n'ont pas dit vraiment plus on
est à l'état de discussions négociations
encore
en effet des négociations des
discussions il y en a eu beaucoup les
quinze derniers jours des disputes des
10 question bilatérale entre plusieurs
ministres de la défense européens
puisque et bien sûr cette force chapeau
bas les pays européens n'étaient pas
forcément sur la même longueur d'onde il
y a ceux qui voulaient partir et ceux
qui voulaient se finalement rester mais
sous un autre format alors emmanuel
macron a annoncé ce matin que des
militaires européens participant à
takouba seront repositionnées aux côtés
des forces armées nigériennes dans la
région frontalière du mali alors le
niger c'est un point d'appui assez
naturel puisque plusieurs pays européens
ont déjà dans ce pays d'émission
bilatérales et puis vous le savez
takouba ce n'est pas la seule force
européenne au mali il ya aussi
l'opération européenne de formation eu
une tm alors l'union européenne on le
sait a l'intention de maintenir sa
présence au mali c'est le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell
qu'il a à nouveau confirmé hier mais les
européens évidemment veulent se montrer
très prudent et ne pas envenimer la
situation avec les autorités maliennes
lui l'union européenne avait déjà
employé de grandes précautions de
langage lorsqu'elle avait décidé et bien
de maintenir sa mission upm lors des
deux coups d'état en 2020 et 2021 merci
beaucoup elle